thank you for joining us America mark is
with us in Chattanooga hey Mark welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show thank you for
taking my call I really appreciate it my
pleasure how can I help my uncle was
killed last night he was hit by a car
crossing the street last night yes sir
oh my gosh and there's already some
family drama surrounding as well and I
was hoping to get your advice on it oh
my goodness how old was he he was 57 oh
goodness
and is he married he he was they've been
separated for several years and I found
out they had planned on he had already
talked to an attorney about filing for
divorce but he hadn't so he's married
right did he have a will he did and his
will was changed this summer my brother
and a cousin of mine were named as the
sole benefactors in his will mm-hmm what
happened today was my brother went out
to his house in Lakota my aunt lives in
North Carolina and he was trying to find
things you know life insurance things so
he could get things rolling to pay for
the funeral and everything and called my
aunt asked her she might nor it was and
she called the police and she doesn't
want anybody out there she's saying that
everything is hers and all belongs to
her and so we're trying to figure out if
there's a way that my brother can kind
of free the assets until the will is
found so that we know what to do with
everything or if she's gonna have
complete control of the executor okay so
you don't have a copy of the will nobody
does correct we're trying to find out
the attorney that he used
hey yeah this is difficult a little
bunch of crap and how much assets does
this guy did this gentleman have that
I'm not sure of my brother roughly is he
a multi-millionaire did he have two
nickels not so sure he was renting the
land he was living on he was a truck
driver so anything he had was in his
home but he didn't have a home
he's a renter right right okay W nothing
just personal belongings and some life
insurance policies life insurance
policies are not part of a will they're
going to Ray the beneficiary regardless
of what the will says right well I'm not
sure it sounds like there's no money
there right pretty much yeah so why are
we fighting over this um sounds like my
aunt is trying to keep anything that he
did have for herself
Merson lot and personal items that's all
he had pretty much yeah yeah so don't
spend $10,000 for $500 worth of garage
sale stuff okay right mm-hmm just
because everybody's mad right so I don't
want to be unkind I'm so sorry y'all are
facing this I mean it was last night for
goodness sakes but um you know he didn't
have anything don't fight about it okay
don't I mean I would spend a lot of time
and emotion on this I do want to try to
I'd be a lot more concerned to find out
if he had life-insurance policies so
that those life insurance companies
could be notified so the beneficiaries
can be on there now if he has $300,000
worth a assets and you want to spend
$10,000 on legal fees to fight with
crazy woman I mean you can do that right
but but you know I if you don't find a
will or if she gets to the will before
you doing tears it up or you can't find
the attorney that's got the will even if
there's a sale
you got a real hard road here okay and
you know has a wife
she's got tremendous position in this
estate if we don't find a will like
she's gonna get it all okay so we've got
to get the will in but again how much
money do you want to spend to get five
hundred dollars worth of items right
yeah so you know I guess that's what you
guys need to determine is there some
assets or not I'm a lot more concerned
about finding out if there's life
insurance policies and the good news is
if he had changed his life insurance
policies for your brother or cousin or
whoever to be the beneficiary there's
nothing she can do about that okay but
you do have to know that they exist and
which insurance company to call and you
know get them a copy of his death
certificate and that kind of stuff in
order to get the claim paid but your
brothers should not pay for the funeral
okay until aunt it releases whatever
funds are available to your brother and
the will to your brother so you know
don't get caught up in that if she's
gonna throw him out of the house because
she wants to own everything then she
gets to pay for the funeral
hello okay you call the cops on me
because I'm in the house trying to
figure all this out and do what his last
wishes were when y'all hadn't lived
together in years then you get to pay
for the funeral cuz you're the one
you're the one wants everything so good
luck with that and you can have this
$500 for the garage sale stuff it's his
old furniture and is you know odds and
ends
other than the nostalgic or the
emotional thing but the actual dollars
involved are very very low is what I
think I'm hearing okay right if that
turns out to be true don't you know
again don't don't get mad spend $10,000
in legal fees fighting for $500 or the
stuff
I'm so sorry though and i han't what a
mess
thank you for calling hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
now
[Applause]
[Music]